each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so hi Breanna and I'm service porosity
this from external research and it is my
great great pleasure to welcome a
professor Paul Watson from newcastle
university as it's now called from from
the UK and I know Paul I have known him
for as we said yesterday for 13 years
now since 95 96 95 and Paul was my PhD
supervisor my mentor and and then my
boss at the geeky science or program
geeky science center in Newcastle and
he's been fantastic he's been a
fantastic commander I've learned so much
and next to him and and it's always a
pleasure seeing him and and then talking
with you so I'm not going to say story i
just want us to allow a polo to start
and he's going to talk to us about so
the wonderful work that they are doing
around cloud services sir for resins
okay thanks Alice so it's a pleasure to
be here again so I'm going to talk about
a project called the cullman project
which which is one of the big UK science
projects which so as you've probably not
Tony kicked off the UK science program
and run it very successful for many
years and every now and again they fund
some large projects which try to see
whether we can apply these science
techniques in particular areas and they
say this is one of them so split into
two strands really so half is going to
be about this particular new informatics
application I should say that I'm not a
I'm not a neuroscientist before in case
anybody starts asking difficult
questions there so I'm a computer
scientist so I pick up where I come from
the neuroscience in in the project and
the the particular approach we've taken
in this in this area's is the cloud
computing approach when we start we
didn't know it was called cloud
computing but that seems to be what
everybody calls it these days I will
talk about how we're dealing with the
the problems of new informatics by
applying a cloud computing paradigm so
the reason we go interest in this was
because although I don't know much about
neuroscience always been fascinated by
the way in which the brain worked and so
being chatting to neuroscientists for
many years and we always in the project
believe that this is the last great
informatics challenge so physicists will
always be keen on finding the something
about a smaller particle than ones who
understand that at the moment but in
terms of human sized endeavor then
understanding more about how the brain
works I think is really important when I
when I start on this I went and bought a
book on neuroscience so you can go to
any year any textbook around it and he
text book shop around the University and
buy books and they're always about so
thick and you sit down and you start to
to read them and after about a hundred
pages your own brain starting to hurt
very much and you're starting to flick
through faster and faster to get to the
chapter called how the brain works and
you never find it and one of the neuro
scientists in the project told me well
you know that's why we need have
projects like this one because we want
to be able to write that chapter so one
of the the big hopes of this project is
that by pursuing these sorts of this
sort of work somebody can write that
Chuck run how the how the brain works so
our hope is that we'll learn something
about computer science course obviously
those there's many things that the brain
can do that computers aren't actually
particularly good at like image
recognition for example learn something
about biology and of course medicine so
a lot of the drugs that are used operate
on there on the brain so hopefully I
understand more about the brain we can
make advances in all of these areas and
here's a thing have to click to kick
this off so this is a this is to show
you the sort of debt or that people are
collecting and operating on so this is
these are some ganglion cells so they
sit between foreign receptors in the
optical nerves so they're mediating
information that's coming in through the
through the retina and what you're
seeing there is these these these dots
the colored dots that these are active
neurons so you can see where's our
activity sweeping through
this part of the brain and this isn't a
this is from a retina of an unborn
turtle and so what they think is
happening here is so there's no actual
light getting to be getting to the
redness or what they think is that a lot
of the brain is very plastic and so what
they think is that this is part of the
process of wiring up the connections in
the brain so it's ready for when the
turtles born Zurich interpret the world
world around it so but they're not
really they're not exactly sure that
this is the case so they collect lots of
day like this and then they try to under
understand what it really really means
and there's a surprisingly large number
of neuro scientists around the world
collecting this sort of date so 100,000
which isn't it much higher than I would
have would have a guest and the collect
information that you can see it all
sorts of different different levels from
the right down to the genomic right up
to me to the behavioral and this creates
a lot of problems so at the moment
although there's lots of data collected
by all these different scientists
unfortunately it's very rarely shared as
you can imagine a lot of this date was
very expensive to collect I'll show you
some data in a few slides time that's
collected from human patients and
there's only one of the operations that
allows you to collect these data takes
place in the hospital in your castle
every month and so they collect this
data broke the mum it's not really
particularly well reused and the reasons
for that effort attentively kept in a
proprietary format to every manufacturer
of of kit that you use to to collect
this data has their own formats for the
for the day and so labs stick with a
particular manufacturer and write all
sorts of analysis routines that only
work with that manufacturers data format
so it's actually very difficult then for
did it to be transferred from one group
to another and for people who are
writing in our search through teens they
can't write January guard analysis
routines you could use an all sort of
all sorts of tend to be very specialized
to the particular kit they have in their
own lab and as a result of this you get
much less collaboration than you might
expect so neuro scientists are aware of
the fact that they have different skills
different expertise some of them are
better at doing the experiments than
they are at the analysis and to really
figure club
read and share and share the announcers
routines that could make quite a lot of
progress but they're not able to do that
at the moment and I just put this in
because this isn't neuroscience of very
clever people in my experience so it's
not just because they're they don't
really know what they're they're doing
this seems to me to be a general problem
in science so as you move around working
on a science project to lots of
different areas you keep seeing this
this again and again and came across
Geoffrey BALCA ones who talked about his
site is standard scientific model and he
says that science takes place in three
stages so first of all people collect
data and then they publish papers on the
data and then they gradually lose the
original data and this this wasn't just
a bar anecdote if you got to this
pibblies analyzed the way in which data
is collected and used in science and
this creates all sorts of problems with
that so so the idea of science one of
the great things about it's supposed to
be the ability to replicate experiment
but actually if you haven't got the dirt
and a lot of the date that we use now is
created by programs rather than just the
original source there we haven't got
this data then how can you replicate
these experiments you are use the data
how can you take other people's data and
see whether your analysis routines when
you apply to their debt give you the
same resources in in your own data so so
this is really calling back not just
neuroscience but lots of sciences and I
would claim you get the same for codes
in science or codes go through the same
stages people write codes to apply the
data they publish papers on it and then
they gradually lose the original court
and that has the same as the same
problems so although the this various
attempts in a number of scientists to
allow people to share data what we
decided to do in the common project was
also try to get them to share the
analysis routines as well so we're
trying to trying to attack both both
problems and so sort of comment to the
rescue so this is the sort of mission
statement of Carmen to allow these
scientists wherever they are to
collaborate and share their analysis
called their debt or and their and their
expertise so this was the this is what
we put forward to a committee of people
including Darren in fact
to remember who thankfully decided to
fund us so it's quite a big project the
the computer science is done by I'm at
Newcastle and Jim Austin's group with
York and then there's neuro scientists
around the country were collecting dirt
and want to use this system to share and
analyze that data and there's a few
companies including Microsoft to of
signed up to support them the project as
well within the project the focus is on
neural activity so I said there's lots
of different sorts of dirt that people
are interested in so neural activities
about so they put one or more electrodes
into the brain and then you get readings
like this and because you can't put
electrode into a specific neuron then
the information you're getting is from a
whole set of neurons around where the
electrode is so the first thing that
they have to do is what they call spike
sorting where they try to work out the
set of neurons which have contributed to
this signal that you're getting out from
me from the electorate as various
techniques to do that and then they have
some way of working out where the spikes
are because although people aren't
really sure how the brain processes
information there's a lot of evidence
that these spikes the way in which
information is is passed through the
different regions of the brain and
processed by the neurons and the idea is
basically to try and understand what on
earth these these spikes mean and that's
it that's a very difficult problem and
the reason why there isn't a chapter at
the moment on how the how the brain
works is because basically you're you're
sampling so because you can stick one
electrode on nowadays an array of
electrodes into the brain you're
sampling from a set of neurons in one
particular part of the brain you don't
know what the connectivity of those
neurons are so you don't know what to
connect it to what you don't know
whether you get an information from all
the neurons you don't know whether the
information you're getting is specific
to the particular place where you've
inserted the electrodes or whether it's
more general so it's very it's very
difficult sometimes am i some Thai draw
the analogy imagine if we were trying to
work understand how integrated circuits
work no we had was a was it was a probe
that we could stick at various points
into a VLSI circuit and on the back of
that we had to work out how her
pentium processor work than it's a it's
a it's a problem of that sort of a sort
of magnitude so here's an is an example
just to to show you about how dare they
might be expensive to collector and we
really want to share it so this is from
a some work that's done at Newcastle
only in the hospital there so every now
and again so roughly twelve times a year
there's a patient presents themselves at
the hospital they've got terrible
problems of epilepsy and it can't be
controlled by drugs and so as a last
resort they remove a part of the brain
in order to try and cure the problem or
at least two to reduce it and in order
to do that they need to work at which
part of the brain to to remove obviously
latter very it's very important that you
remove the the right partner Mora on or
less so what they do is they they open
up the brain and they use electrodes in
order to gather information and they
move the electrodes around and to live
like it at the part that they think
causes the problem and then they remove
it and then they analyze the the slice
they've removed while it lives so they
can oxygenate it and keep it in drugs
for somewhere between minutes to hours
and gather some information so they can
do this once a month and they collect
the data and then largely the group
that's collected it uses that data but
as I've said the problem is that it's
not particularly shared so this it's not
as if it's easy for another group
somewhere else to take that data and
apply their own analysis routines to it
to combine it with debt from other
hospitals so um so this is a warning so
I know some people don't uh don't like
seeing a medical photograph so the next
two slides are going to show an exposed
to human brain so look away now if you
if you don't want to see it I've
starting to go to neuroscience
conferences and they don't give you any
warnings there so sometimes you can
always jump out your seat but here we go
so this is the part of the brain where
they where they think the problem is so
they've removed that part of the skull
to prepare it and then you can see there
the this two sets of four electrons
being placed on the brain and the
surgeon will move those around and look
at the signals coming out and when they
think they've located the area then
they'll remove that that part of the
part of the brain
so they're all past it now so anybody
not looking can can look again there's
no more slides like that and this is the
information that they're they're getting
out of the brain and actually for the
for the part where that causes the
problem with epilepsy it's usually what
you get is you get a part where there's
there's not really very much activity
but and the surrounding areas there's
lots of activity so it's almost as if
the part of the brain which is causing
the problem blocks the flow of signals
around that part of the brain so you see
the more building up around that area
and then a very dead area which is the
part that they remove okay this in the
more so when it came to trying to work
out what we needed to do to it to
address this then key thing here is to
be able to share so sharing data and
code as I've said we're trying to share
the analysis routines as well as just
the debt that's collected from the
experiment and the capacities can be
quite large so so I've said vast so I
guess to come like Microsoft 100
terabytes isn't very big but it is to us
compared to lots of other a science
project so we've clicked that from the
scientists in the project within the
next couple of years each one of the
problems is that as these techniques
come on then you get more and more data
collected so when we started the project
started writing the proposal single
electrode recording was quite common and
then multiple electoral recording came
in so that moved from say one electrode
to about 60 and now they're going up to
about 500 of these electrodes that they
stream from all the time and then the
video techniques which I showed you that
gives you a factor of 10 more more data
so it went from tens of megabytes per
experiment up two gigabytes or even in
some of the bigger experiments terabyte
in it in a single experiment in the
course of in the course of two or three
years and this is only going to increase
as these video techniques start to start
to take over and once you've got that
sort of dare of course you have to
analyze it and this can take a very long
time so I had some in my office last
week estimated that there an ostrich
routine would take half a year to run on
some of these some of these datasets
that we'd that we'd collect it so so you
need to need to be able to share very
large amount of debt we need to have
some way of running these announcers
routines on it so we came up with this
cloud architecture for it so the idea is
that if you've got a cloud to somewhere
just out there over the Internet where
people can upload their debt then it's
easy for them to share it because they
can just change permissions on it and
other people can see it doesn't have to
be physically transferred and keep so
once you've uploaded their data they can
also upload services so this was the
idea so it would be nice to have a fixed
set of services that would support the
needs of the neuroscientist we just
provide them out there in the cloud they
would upload their they would choose
what to do run it and analyze the data
and visualize the results in practice of
course being been scientists what
happens is they're driving into work on
the morning and they come up with a new
algorithm and they want to code that up
and apply to all the debt or in the
system so we need to tab somewhere so
that users could not just upload data
could also upload code to to run to
analyze their their day or as well and
then so once you once you've got your
day up there and the services are up
there then users can run analysis so
that is the run analyses out there
somewhere just using a web browser and
they can visualize the the results so
that's that's quite a common cloud sort
of model these days perhaps the thing
which is a bit different about it is
they need to be able to dynamically
upload services to run on the run on the
day
upload this analysis at the
well yeah I'll talk a bit more about
that later but we so we we get people to
wrap everything they do is web services
because we wanted to have some sort of
standard for it and we can actually cook
with having the web services in a vm but
we can cope with it in lots of different
ways as well so war files dot net
assemblies so as long as we've got some
sort of deployer for it then then we can
handle it but the only way the only
restriction we have is it's got to be
wrapped as a web service we've got some
sort of common way to deal with it to
put security round it to compose it with
other services and so there's quite a
lot of interest is you know in cloud
computing so so one approach to this
would be to just so we're wheel will
provide some low-level storage and
computer so this is kind of the I
suppose the Amazon approach where you
can buy storage and s3 and you can run
things in in ec2 and then we could say
ok and then you just write your signs up
above that and we didn't want to do that
what we wanted to do is to try to think
about well are there any services that
we could factor out that we could
provide once and then people could just
use them so people could move up the
value chain just write specific services
at the top so based on the last five or
six years of running a science projects
we sat down and thought about well what
were these comments what were these
common services that we'd want to want
to provide and so so we rejected that
option and basically we ended up with
with this so these are the services that
we we came up with in the cloud so this
is basically our our cloud here and
there's a set of services in there we
run it on our own cluster at the moment
I'll talk later on about why we don't
run it on Amazon are or wherever but
we've got our own cluster to run it on
and so if I go through the services so
you want to be surprised that we need
somewhere to distort data's so the raw
data goes into files because it's a
basic time series data and then we also
have a database in fact sequel server
that we can use to store secondary data
that we've produced from those fire
and then we have to have some way of
describing these files because the
scientists have to be able to look for
data is collected in particular sorts of
experiments or by particular groups so
we've got a metadata store in there and
when scientists upload their data from
their web browsers over the far end over
there then they fill in forms to
describe the matter that we've got some
on told you that we've devised we use
some general anthologies from biology
which are used basically just to
describe the experimental process and
then there's some specific ontology that
we've had to produce for
electrophysiological data because none
existed before the project started so so
we end up with your data and your your
metadata here and then and I'll talk
about this in more detail but we've also
got a repository for the services that
people have uploaded and then we've got
a cluster and when people want to run
these services on the day and we can
take the services and deployable form
from this repository and deploy it on
1and1 notes in and run it in the cluster
we've gotta work for an acumen engine
because workflows have been successful
lots of differently science projects
they're not particularly well used by
neuroscientist at the moment but our
experience with biologists sees that
there are valuable where for people to
compose together different analysis
codes so people don't have to write a
siloed routine which does everything
people are good a visualization can read
visualization routines and compose it
with somebody else's go to statistical
analysis and compose it with somebody
else is good at spikes or and routines
so workflow allows people to combine
these processes together to do and to
share them and so we want it to run that
in the in the cloud as well because
obviously the danger is if you've got
your work for a nap and engine out is is
commonly the case on the users desktop
and all they would have to fly backwards
and forwards and it would take a very
long time if you try and analyze
terabytes of data so at the moment we're
using taverna so that's that's largely
because there historically that's the
one that we've used and got the
expertise with but we're not we're not
completely tied to it we could move to
anything else as long as it would run
in the cloud remotely sorry state well
yes we might we'd have to apply for
permission but I guess we could get oh
yeah that's a look that screensaver I
think so yeah so then we've got a
registry which allows people to search
for the day or in the analysis services
that they that they're interested in and
we've got a security wrapper for this
system so neuroscience like lots of
scientists aren't the sort of people who
are just happy with the idea of sharing
all of their debt as soon as it comes
out of the experiment so they really
want to get those nature and science
papers written and published before they
allow anybody else to to see it we've
done lots of requirements analysis with
all these different groups of neuro
scientists that we've got involved in
the project and it's quite interesting
at the first reaction when you say and
once the dirt is uploaded who would you
like to be able to see it the initial
reaction is always me and then they
think well and yeah and maybe my
students and perhaps later my
collaborators and so on but really you
need quite a fine-grained security
system running there before anybody
would consider uploading any day or into
the into the cloud so we've we've got a
system where once you've uploaded the
day you can decide who's allowed to see
it and you can then change it over time
as you allow more and more people to to
have access to it and then we've got the
the people accessing this over the web
on a unlit on the left-hand side Roger
service
yeah so that's so that's that that's
that's a very good point so we have
actually got somebody working on a
prominent service but we didn't commit
to it at the beginning of the project
because we've never written one before
we couldn't find one that we'd that was
just available to drop into the system
but you're right that that will be a
very valuable addition of these services
in the service repository for this use
then probably something you have to be
built in I think we'd have to be built
in because it has to it has to have
probes into all the other things going
on so every time you run a workflow you
want it's a record who ran it what the
workflow was which services are called
and so on so I think you would have to
be a one of these sort of first-class
services rather than they these analysis
services here which your then
choreographing using the workflow and
the provenance is recording what
actually happened ok so I'll say a
little bit about one of these things
which actually picks up on the question
I had earlier so so this system that
we've had for a few years now which
which allows us to have this code
repository so this thing called called
dinosaur which actually saw us worked on
anything and its early stages so the
basic idea is that we wrap code is web
services so we stick to WSI web services
because we want to have them to be
interoperable we don't want to have to
go back to everybody in year or twos
time lassen to change to whatever the
latest new web service standard is so SS
I seems quite conservative and it seems
to do what we want so we stick to that
and it means that the internals aren't
are important to people and right
services in Java a lot of neuroscientist
right in matlab and this proved to be
quite a quite a pain for us because of
the licensing model so we had one person
technically looking at how we might run
matlab in the cloud another person
reading the small print of all of the
the matlab documentation to make sure we
wouldn't be here wouldn't be in prison
or fine for for doing this but we think
we've we've cracked both of both of
those so there's a MATLAB compiler that
you can use and once you produce the
output of that
you can run it without a license so
that's what we that's what we do so we
can support MATLAB services as well as
as well as any others and the key thing
is just that um whatever you've got then
you have a deployer for it so once
you've got this service in your
repository you just need somewhere to
deploy it so we've done virtual machines
thinks of us did this one running many
years ago the virtual pc pc one the.net
assemblies we can we can also deploy and
even jim gray one suggested to us that
we should be able to deploy services in
a database so we've done that as well so
we can deploy services right into a
sequel server as well if that makes
sense to see if having a transfer debt
are in and out of the in and out of the
day a bit and so this is the way it this
is the way it works in a bit more detail
so the first time you call a service so
basically all services have endpoints
dis ordinary service endpoint as far as
the clients concerned it doesn't see any
difference from from a normal service
and what happens is that the client
sends the result message to this to this
endpoint which is owned by a web service
provider and it then sends it to
somewhere it can be anywhere where we
have these things called host providers
and they're in charge of the compute
resources and it's not necessarily the
case that the service has to be deployed
at the time when it arrives at the host
provider because the web service
provider when it gets the request it
inserts into that request the handle of
a place where a horse variety can go to
get a deployable version of the service
and deployed if necessary so that's
gonna what's going to happen in this
case so this is for service s4 and s4
isn't deployed on any of these nodes so
request goes out to the service
repository deployable version of the
service comes back and is deployed on a
node and then the request can go to that
node and run and then the result
returned to the to the client so best
little where so that we can build up
this repository of services yeah
oh that's so that would just be a
processor yeah so in our system at the
moment this is a cluster so these are
each of the the nodes in the cluster you
are send your dad man your java database
what are you offering linux and windows
a nice equal and see what these things
are in training so they the cluster at
the moment is the linux cluster but the
infrastructure which supports dinosaur
could be ported to anything I saw Buster
a few years ago got a partner working on
dotnet quite quite over weekend word so
it's always over a weekend with salad no
that one was that was a native
implementation yeah but this one knows
this could be written looking do you
support or not no no we're not tried it
with mono I guess I guess we could but
it is at yeah yeah but yeah well we have
yeah we we have done in the past but in
the current system then we couldn't run
those at the moment except that you
could put them into a virtual machine
and then we could deploy those and run
so so that would work but yeah at the
moment the host provider is so this is
the component that you'd have to port to
another soil machine so at the moment
this runs on linux platform in the
carmen project once once you've deployed
the service then it for subsequent calls
then they just get routed to a deployed
version of the the service so there's no
overhead every time you you call the
service it just gets gets sent to that
node which which is running the service
so one of the attractions of this is
that when we started to use virtual
machines things like dot wore feathers
net assemblies you might end up with 10
20 megabytes representing your service
as soon as you go to virtual machines it
goes up and can be five six seven
gigabytes it takes quite a long time to
move these onto an Oden and deploy it
but the attraction of this way of doing
it is that once it's deployed you don't
have to move it every time
just you can stare them so you the cost
of deploying it gets aggregated across
all of the different indications that
you may that service once it once it's
there so cost in the way that you know
time to deploy you know an instance of
something in the event you do have to
get removed from the house tour yeah so
we've done some work on that and that's
have a after this I'll come back to that
in one in one slide time Darren so I
thought was this slide but it's actually
the the next one so this just gives you
an idea of the some costs so this was
this was where we were investigating
what it would be like if we didn't
deploy the services close to the day so
this be the case where calm was just a
debt repository and people were running
the analysis routines on their local
system and this is some tuples each each
of these tools was a was a few hundred
bytes coming from this database of
enders analysis service so this purple
line shows what happens if the analysis
service was remote from the date of
birth and you can see that for this
particular analysis routine you pay a
high price for transferring their the
data so as the this is logarithmic so as
the number of tuples requested goes up
you your it's really starting to cost
you an awful lot to move the dirt around
with dinosaur when you switch dinosaur
on so then you move the analysis team
close to the database and you can see
that the the cost drops considerably so
this yellow line is the cost the first
time you call the service using dinosaur
so this includes the cost of of
deployment and then after that this is
the the cost once it's deployed so so
this would be the cost of the second and
subsequent call to the the service down
here so so you can see you do pay a cost
in there in the deployment but once you
once you've done that then the overhead
is it turns out actually quite a low of
having dinosaur in the system right so
is the answer to Darren's question so so
we played around with various algorithms
this is the most sophisticated one that
we've tried so this is the one which
tries to keep the the response time
constant for a service as you increase
the number of requests and so it does
that by monitoring the time that
taking to process each request and then
deploy multiple versions of the service
in order to give you two to give you
more concurrent services which are able
to process requests of this type so if
you start over here so this is quite a
low arrival rate and we've got two
processes here which are able to process
the request and the response times down
here in response time as the arrival
rate increases the response imma keep
steady because the system keeps
deploying more and more services on
different nodes you can see that the
number of services those square boxes
that goes up to 24 6 and so on and this
this sort of works until you get to
about 12 processes and then after that
if the rival rate increases then we run
out of nodes we've only got 16 notes and
the system can't cope with this arrival
rate beyond that so this is another
attraction we think of having the
services in deployable form and
repository because you can reap lot you
can deploy multiple instances of them in
order to scale up the performance if
they if a service becomes popular and of
course you can then get rid of services
if the if the arrival rate drops and
there's been some work some some people
howdy partner interested in queueing
theory and mathematical model have done
some analysis which sure when you should
get rid of get rid of services as well
because they might affect other more
popular so so we're trying to get this
balanced you've got a fixed set of nodes
you've got a set of services which
people want to use and you're trying to
decide how to partition up the nodes
across them
still the response times during Chris
yeah well once you get to to here then
you just haven't got the power even when
you've deployed this service on sixty
nodes to deal with all of these
requesters they come in and so at this
point then you really have to buy a
bigger cluster in order to keep the
response time at this level for that
sort of arrival right just assuring you
so so this is just round robin load
balancing for this experiment so you so
how are many deployments they are you
just round-robin the requesters that
come in across them so it may be that we
could do something more more more
sophisticated with that I was just stir
in the 1980s I work with a group that
did a lot of work on unload balancing
scheduling and people people would write
phd's for study this for three or four
years and then discover that that random
was actually the best approach around
Robin so I've always I've never really
tried to do anything more sophisticated
in that area since so um okay so so
that's one bit of the technology I'll
just go to to end we'll go through a
typical scenario so this is the sort of
thing that we when we looked at the
requirements from the neuroscience this
is the sort of thing that they wanted to
do so they start off they collect for a
multi-electrode array so this is a
multi-electrode array so you'd so that
you saw the the brain earlier when the
slice was taken off would be placed on
top of there and then each of these
individual electrons and you can read
out for them from them by connecting to
these pads around here they would the
neuroscience would want to have a look
at the data they would want to make sure
that we're getting some signals from it
and they might move the slice around if
they weren't getting a very good
response from it or they might try
different drugs or whatever until they
were getting something which the felt
was worth worthy of analysis when they
do the spike detection and
sorting that I talked about earlier
working out how they thought that the
signal which you've got was spread
around the set of neurons they do some
sort of statistical analysis to try to
work out what the what the spikes that
they'd identified meant and then they'd
visualized the the results and then this
was a semi manual process which involved
lots of so we found one group were even
for small amounts of debt or it took
them about a day to analyze it because
of doing data format conversion between
the date as it came out of the electrode
array kit and the analysis routine and
they were putting everything through an
Excel spreadsheet in small chunks
manually in order to do the data
conversion so that was one thing that we
were able to fix so if I go through
these very quickly these stages so this
is the so this so I said that this is
about cloud computing and the idea is to
move everything the cloud and every
everything uses a browser so this is the
exception that proves the rule so this
is a tool that Jim Austin's group at
you're built for the dam project which
is one of the projects that Tony funded
which is about looking at aircraft
engines so actually this feature here so
that so in in the classic example of
this for aircraft engines this would be
a bird strike so they'd have a
particular partner identified for a bird
strike that want to find all occurrences
of it and all the data from aero engines
that they've collected but this is
actually from a from one of those
electrode arrays so you can see these
are each of the electrodes in their own
you can see there's a these spikes here
so the neuroscientists would would have
a look at this and they'd zoom zoom
along and have a look at their 4a
through through the dirt at various
times and just make sure that they were
they were getting signals and they were
happy with it before they decided to
analyze it so this is one tool so this
is actually a Windows application it
windows application that runs on the
desktop and the people at York say it
couldn't be put into the into the cloud
because of the the nature of the
interaction with the user and trying to
get the data backwards and fold between
the cloud in there and the tool so
this is what you can also do with this
tool so the single Derek's plurality of
the Torah showed at the top left then
you can kick off searches which are sent
very close to their data so the debt is
stored in these storage resource brokers
which is a file management system and
you can search for particular patterns
and it moves the patterns as close as
possible to the debt or in order to
reduce the amount of information that's
being sent in and out of there in and
out of the system so the idea is that
only a small amount of data should be
sent between the cloud and the the
desktop tool and yeah so what happens is
you kick off these searches and then
anytime the the client can request to
have a look at some of the positive
results that have been sent back until
the user can then browse through so so
typically in this case would be looking
for a particular sort to spike activity
video yeah yeah you'll have to talk to
some of us about exact way it works but
yeah so that so basically on each on
each node I need to know to deploy a
local SRB which can then you can then
send the the requests to my team of
never seen anybody could really use this
are these all right they just believe
all right well
is this RV deity yeah and so and the
people of yoga ginger and expert in
different ways to do searching so
they've got lots of different searching
techniques which are efficient and scale
well across a across the set of nodes so
we define the the process of that the
users were doing with a workflow that
takes in the dirt at did some analysis
so this is written in our oath and
matlab so Ari's tend to be used by
people who who don't want to use matlab
because its proprietary but not
everybody can use our to do what they
want it turns out because matlab comes
with lots of libraries which work for
things like signal processing which
actually very useful for what the
neuroscientist want to do and you can't
do everything with with us so in this
case the our code is actually doing some
statistical analysis once you've
identified where the spikes are in a
producer some output you can see at the
bottom so this is an early version of
the port or which were not usability
experts are interface design experts but
it just gives you an idea of what you
can do so you can see the data that you
have access to on the on the left-hand
panel over here and you can select some
dirt so in this case this result of this
experiment you can have a look at what
workflows are available and you can
click and select to to run a workflow it
runs in the cloud and then you get the
results back so this is one of the
graphs that's produce this is actually
showing me so the density of the the
black line shows the rate of spiking
activity two particular lectroids you
can see this is this is one of those
waves which is flowing across from one
part of the electrode array across to
another part and then they also like
visualizations something's quite crude
ones but effective so this one which may
start on its own account remember it
reels so this is just for each electrode
the radius of the circle you can see
shows the the rate of firing of the
neurons under that part of the circle
and it is quite you see the activity you
can see the flow of the activity across
a across a slice quite well like that
much easier than if you just got graphs
or printouts of numbers
okay so just to finish quickly so common
is aiming to deliver new results in
neuroscience and hopefully computer
science and if we can apply some of the
results of the neuroscience in medicine
as well and we're delivering through a
new science cloud that allow the folks
this talks be on neuroscience our hope
in trying to identify what are those
common building blocks that you'd want
to have in the cloud our hope is that
we'll be able to use them for other
sorts of science as well so one of the
new project which we have which is
funded so one northeast is a Regional
Development Authority for the northeast
of England and they've funded a pilot
study looking at how you can apply this
approach to other sciences so we've got
some money to go and look at what
scientists to take their codes wrap them
up with services put them in the system
and provide this sort of system to to
use this and I think I've got another
yeah so this is the this is the vision
here so you've got basically your basic
set of e-sign services at the bottom
you've got some core scientific services
that are independent of any particular
science and then in particular domains
so that I picked these these four
domains over here because these are for
that the Regional Development Authority
has said are going to be important for
the northeast of England and they're
pumping money into that they're also
interested in building up sets of data
and services that can be used for skills
and education both in universities and
also in schools in there and the area
and there's no reason why you have to
just stick with science services are
being looking at some business services
as well so it's quite interesting that
if you look at so the Northeast isn't a
high-tech hotbed of in there in the in
the UK there's this odd pocket of
expertise but the companies are often
small in it and they struggle to get
going and one of the things that one of
these has been trying to do is to make
it easy for them for people to set up
companies in to run companies and
there's quite a few people who will host
business applications like these want a
project management and CR
and so on for a for a monthly cost for
these for these small companies and the
wreath and the Regional Development
Authority scheme to subsidize that
encourage people to do that to get off
the ground without big investment so the
idea is to make these available as well
through the same sort of platform so so
one of the users in a in a start-up or
in a in a university would log on to the
system and then be presented with a set
of services that could narrow it down to
that particular scientific area that you
look at the business service or whether
they could they could run them and so
that hopefully they could do a lot of
their work within this sort of a sort of
environment without having to investing
in people or software because it seems
like the upfront capital cost of start
of creating a start-up in into science
area like bio bio science can be quite
large and hopefully this moving more
towards us or pay-as-you-go type
approach could reduce those costs I
think I've got one more yeah so this was
the this was the hope that quote the top
that's the hope from from the Regional
Development Authority so they think they
can sell it to businesses that could
come into the area and just get all the
software that they want it for a for a
low cost they're also interesting
because we're adding we're adding social
networking features into it so they're
always interested because you've got
lots of small companies out of it they
build up these relationships between
them how do you build a community and
again you can you can do that with with
that very last slide some move on to so
so for a company like such as such as
this one that's looking at commercial
clouds and so on then this is this could
address a real problem that that there
is in in science which is sustainability
so it's a real worry for us in our users
that we've got four years funding and
they put a lot of effort into writing
the applications and uploading the debt
and then what happens at the end of the
four years we've really got no
guarantees work because we're a
university we're really pitching to do
research rather than to create these
systems and a maintainer of a long
period of time so I've been looking at
commercial cloud so for example the one
from from amazon at the moment and
whether we could
whether we could use that and the
attraction of that it might save us from
using the having to provide our own
storage and compute so we wouldn't have
to run our own our own cluster and the
idea would be to find somewhere moving
from the our own private cluster over to
use amazon facilities perhaps in a
controller and there's a local company
who actually saw us used to work for it
as well whoo-hoo we've been doing some
work with and they're looking at this
area at how you move from your private
internal cluster over to exit external
resources like white amazon so that
might be away over time to migrate off
our own system to to something else but
there's a it still gives this problem
because if you look at back of that
stack that i told you about earlier so
we've got this storage in compute needs
which commercial cloud like amazon could
provide but then this still leaves all
of these services in the middle here
which we have to build and support and
maintain if these users are able up the
top real user out yeah Roger chasm that
actually runs on these
well you can you could do that but of
course it would still need some
maintenance and you'd still have to
upgrade it and so on so it's science
project yeah I think that so I think
that's a good idea and I think that's
the way that you would you would
organize this but you know software
seems to atrophy over a period of time
if you just leave it and you know
there's always security patches that
need to be applied or somebody wants to
just add in this extra feature or you
know my feelings if we just effectively
frozen virtual machines what what was
around at the time then these users
would would find that it over time it
would meet less and less of their needs
and they'd have to move to something
else so my feeling is that you need some
people who are responsible for
maintaining and supporting it at this
level Lee yeah the the security services
that work for service isn't and so on
and then the scientists can concentrate
on their own services at the top yeah so
that's where we see the the gap at the
moment so yeah so so that's the question
at the moment you know provide how do we
support these these e-science services
so we've so we so we've been looking at
whether a company could do this so we
started to get for the first time in my
career start to get involved in thinking
about whether we should look to have a
company which would actually try to
provide this which would look at the
full range of things from here to here
but even then you know it's Roger points
out then the more that commercial
companies could do in this area here it
would really reduce the amount of effort
that you have to do up here in order to
provide services for users over a period
of time so that's a company that we're
setting up late design
oh yes Steve Andy Keynes completely
delivering optimization services perhaps
yeah I didn't know about Simon's were
not very so we should talk to me out
yeah okay i'm not sir that's basically
it telugu mechanics problem you have is
this UK university center field
this is something this is infrastructure
Malaysian dream that's really the
fundamental from command ism it seems to
be the research councils across the
infrastructure spending per project
basis yes it's brooks of water in which
case that's the university yeah so I
mean basically mean it really is a shift
in attitude to me in the wind as to what
is so I don't think that there is from
what I've seen I think there's this
pressure from funders now but say that
people must make publicly available the
results of their project but it's not at
all clear how you how you do that there
isn't a group out there which could take
your day around and your services I mean
at the moment a lot the focus is on data
but really dead on its own is pretty
it's pretty useless we could give it end
of the project 100 terabytes to somebody
who could put it on it on a disk but it
wouldn't be useful nobody could afford
to download it to to analyze it so you
really need a combination the tooling
we've not seen anything that it's there
which is which is looking to do that
very institutions
Russian princess
sounds so so a few years ago I suggested
that yeah
so a few years ago I suggested that that
what the National Grid service should
move into would be something which so I
kind of took me the google the phrase
the google used to describe them
themselves which is my organizing the
world's information i said that why
doesn't the National Grid so it's moved
to being ought to be something which
organized the UK's science information
so it would take not just the codes
which the National Grid service has the
capability to do the the omi I which for
those you not familiar with there with
the odd UK terminology so this is a
group that again Tony set up which is to
to look yeah yes of course okay sir guy
so this through this three people who
know it very well but yes yes this
fantastic system yeah so so that was set
up to to allow people to to effectively
it would take detik services that would
produce cool that was produced by UK
science project and it would get it to
the point where other people could
download it and install it and maintain
it and produce new versions and
documentation and so on it did a good
job of that so on the one side you've
got the National Grid service which
would run things on the other side you
had the oh my i which would produce
software that you could download and
install and but really i felt that you
know what's needed now is bringing all
this together so there's somewhere where
you can have in one place you can have
your data you can have the services that
some there's some group that which will
look after those services so that nobody
needs to download and install anyone
that was the attraction really moving to
the to the cloud model that it seemed
that that was the worthy that computer
world was going and you can imagine in
that model if you could get some people
who would provide these basic services
and get the scientists just concentrate
on their own specific services up at the
top but i have not seen anything like
that that exists at the moment and
that's why we wondered about having to
go ourselves to see whether so the first
part of this project with them with one
northeast will
we'll be going around scientists at the
University and some local companies and
seeing whether this sort of cloud model
really really works for them or not and
if it does then hopefully be able to
work out I hope to provide on a
commercial basis you know how much does
it cost to actually so so the problem
with Amazon is the people focus on just
the low-level cost of cycles and storage
and they don't concentrate on the cost
of maintaining the the software above it
so I'm hoping this will give us a better
idea of how much that would actually
cost you to provide this sort of system
to to use it I'll interesting Kepler
folks in UC Davis and they were
complaining about how the omi I and made
the Taverna code documented it well
engineered unfair competition then we'd
is achieved something the other one that
you talked to how it's our way and his
team they have developed thing they go
s4 which is simple storage services for
science okay
but we good
that idea were resourceful so I'll take
my question we have a product to buy a
suit of girls ages on CA make that can
survive 4matic the other how do you
compare this with them gosh aren't you
talking to the burbs yes yes I'm there
on Monday thing to see a big I'm on the
other end of resizing you highlighted
that fact to rightly start for emea will
see the major problem area is the
medical community because any medical
community is such that you don't want to
share your and yeah so how they have you
structure in place with me you little
see a big is not that much that
subsequently be similar problem so you
think the reason why people don't use is
because they were look to share with
others well that's part of it that's not
actually all of it I'm important there's
a barrier to entry in regards to
actually picking up the technology also
there
favorite instantiations or levels of
participation and hoops that you have to
jump through in order to become members
centers of excellence like Georgia Tech
have already jumped through those hoops
but other institutions haven't been
quite so fortunate doing that and also
the other problem is that they do 10 min
from some of minority areas and not
where most of the actual oncology
research takes place which is eighty
percent of it takes place at the
regional level not at these national
centers of excellence for actually more
academic institutions right so doctrine
actually a lot of reasons to lack of
adopt revision I think it's a completely
other issue from from from this
particular system here I think that this
is a great model in fact that's probably
a better model model in which that
system space but also you need to make
certainly do not sow and confuse the
concept of putting the date on the cloud
and Sarah just because your data is in
the cloud does not mean that you serve
the data or your google main is in the
cloud the part of Google accessing it no
one else you know get on set sharing but
that's the price of it because this has
been part of our this will be important
discussion who can with burn and then
see if we they know they faced
spits me that wood beams & to know what
users actually use the bird for example
they give all these neuroscientists
clovis on door and SRP do they really
need that what is that what they want so
i would be gifted
if you have some insights into that and
simply with CAA I mean I've come out to
the view after mistakenly pursuing a
middleware approach the five years in
the UK science burger that we need to do
a web service cloud service just happen
this year capable what's behind the web
services is that middle working hard web
services but you don't require the user
you don't eight hundred thousand lines
of global software on their server are
quite prevalent for abuse I think I had
to danger with the word clouds are at
the moment of people see clouds as being
like these as I've said these low-level
amazon services and then in order to do
anything you do actually need to build
your own middle arrow on top of that so
i think it's this whole here that's the
that's the problem and who's going to
fill that in the cloud well that would
be very nice gentleman at the back
um so so we have that because our
collaborators York that's their
technology and that's their that's their
interest it certainly so we certainly
use it's been certainly useful in other
applications like the the aero engine
application but den was a successful
project and it was used in rolls-royce
the neuroscientists really like being
able to review their data so they love
the signal data Explorer tool that I
showed at the moment it's not clear
whether these searching facilities are
as useful in that environment as they
are in the aero engine environment
because searching for spikes with
particular characteristics is something
that some neuroscientists do but many
neuroscience are actually just happy to
accept that any voltage which is below a
certain level is a spike they don't care
about the particular shape of the the
spike and so you can easily just Thresh
all the dirt to find the spikes so it's
like yeah
brush and being able to recognize things
that you might not even have a heuristic
for how to recognize right you know that
a super nova flare looks like this kind
of curve particular area of the sky okay
and I can imagine trying to escape sort
of thing here he wants to be able to
grow the way you can even ask questions
you don't have to say show me the
supernovas and show me the things that
aren't super noting or anything else but
still might be interesting but being
able to search across you know terabytes
of data with single experiment it all
seems like a puzzle that it's not going
to be like just why me all of those
spikes you know now there's there's only
40 million now for you ah well so so I
suggested that you get in touch with are
they there get in touch with Jim's group
because they have used this sort of
technology in many different bones of
the do facial recognition with it for
for example they don't just do this they
sort of spike spike detection or stress
the temperature its technology based on
the new rule networks or what yeah yeah
so they've done a lot of work on neural
networks has been away so in correlation
matrices that i mentioned that comes
from one of their neural network
techniques and they've they've got
things like they've got accelerator
hardware as all to make this to make
this faster if if the software agents
aren't quick enough for the amount of
data that you have so that they've got a
lot of expertise in that you know
commercial stuff
silence I bula yeah bul in yeah early
the guy's name is a is Jim Austin aus TI
n you wanted to contact them at York
University's it's helpful so you would
be interested sure and ask you that you
mention that you're using some
biological anthologies yeah
are you using those to see if data is
from commensurate experiments or can you
say do people ontology extremely good
yeah so so amongst the neuroscience that
we work with there's no tradition of
using ontology and very little tradition
of of having any sort of greed word to
describe metadata so if i go back to
just do one of these slides to show them
so you'll show the problem then this
yeah so this sure this so this
was the only metadata before so we we
produce this to mimic some day that was
made available to us and the only
metadata that was available when it was
produced which you can see the title of
it at the top yeah so and that way and
that was it so you had to know what
spiky stuff 0003 was in order to
interpret that information you know what
experiment it came from so so what we've
got is we've got people who have been
involved in in the bioinformatics in
ontology and they have looked at
neuroscience and they've tried to define
well actually what they've done is to
carry over some of the biological and
told is for experimental protocol and
then just fill in the gap with which is
the electrophysiological date for which
there wasn't an ontology at all and now
we're in the process of doing use of
trials to see what the users think of
this and of course it's it's quite
difficult so you know on the on the one
hand I should draw this as a graph but
on the one hand the more information you
get them to produce then potentially
more shareable non-turbo that there is
but as you go in that direction the less
likely it is that people actually bother
to to add it or we're trying to find
where that that's what a minima is where
people are prepared to provide the data
but it's actually useful for a full of
us to use so I expect it's going to be a
human problem as much as a technological
problem
thank you very much